all right Cass sandbar from the expanse
you're here at the Saturn Awards how
exciting is this for you as a person who
takes part in the sci-fi series but also
in the geek stuff are you is this like
just like you being back 10 years old I
love I love that this Awards has become
bigger and bigger and bigger I love that
the Nerds and the geeks who should
inherit the earth by the way are getting
more notoriety more acknowledgment I
mean I've got the incredible doug jones
standing beside me from Star Trek
discovery I just saw Jamie Lee Curtis
walk by was being honored this year and
there's a I met Joss Whedon Favreau and
like it's just an amazing group of
people all of whom even if I wasn't in
the industry I would be kind of like
totally fanboying over yeah and for the
fact that this award is getting bigger
and bigger means that this group of
people and this kind of work is being
more and more
acknowledged by everyone and I really
kind of admire that because science
fiction fantasy and all the genre work
really does have a lot of important
relevance to our society in the sense
that it's one of the only ways we can
tell some of them the allegories that we
want to say in a way that everyone can
kind of identify with it without
finger-pointing at any particular group
of people because it's all kind of
expanded a level to to to the level of
science fiction or fantasy so everyone
can kind of like say oh okay I get what
they're trying to say they're not
exactly pointing me out but I get what
they're trying to say and it's a great
way to teach that's a great way to tell
stories how much pride do you feel and
what the expanse has been able to do
because the expanse is like this the
little engine that could it keeps
fighting and pushing upwards of the
seasons and you get a rabid fan base for
the expanse how do you feel about like
I'm what pride you take on the show we
are hugely proud of the expanse because
we've always believed in the show and
the material the creative team behind it
is like top top top notch we have like
producers and show runners from Breaking
Bad and Star Trek and
all these amazing places that plus the
the material comes from New York Times
bestselling novels that have coming with
a fan base all by themselves for the
past decade so we're starting at like a
really high level before we even air the
first episode we've always been proud of
the work and the writing room has taken
the material to the next level it's
incredibly socially relevant it's him
it's an it's amazingly socio-political
it challenges a lot of kind of concepts
that that traditional sci-fi has put out
there we're extremely realistic in terms
of the science in our show which adds
many layers of challenge to what we're
doing but it adds so much realism to it
that the audience really gets drawn into
the fact that this is really happening
right this is where we're going and it's
not we don't pussyfoot around we don't
candy-coat it we don't sugarcoat it it's
really like be careful guys because if
you're not we could end up in a place
where this dystopian reality actually
exists and we are fractured and in
conflict and on the brink of an
interstellar war because we're human
beings were flawed we're greedy were
selfish we don't listen to each other
and that's kind of what we take pride in
is the fact that we didn't pull any
punches I think that's why people love
the show it's it's gritty and it's real
in the world of sci-fi which at times
can be a little too finished look too
polished little glossy you guys get into
the dirt that would naturally be there
as human beings going forward in the
future a lot of sci-fi tries to say hey
guys follow what we're saying and you
could end up in this beautiful place
which is great because it gives you
sometimes it gives you something to
shoot for and what we're saying is be
careful guys because if you're not you
could end up here right and it's and
even here we still allow ourselves some
room to kind of save ourselves
absolutely we're not too far gone but
we're saying the way you're going now
this is kind of what you're looking at
in 300 years so wake up yeah that's
awesome
Mel smell the soy coffee all right Cass
thanks so much for the time continued
success with expanse man you know
collateral yeah season four is gonna
start in December and I'm gonna start
shooting season five in October so you
guys got two more seasons to look at at
least that's awesome Thank You cat